These are Android Wear watches.
The first thing that you'll notice
is that they don't look like other
Android devices.
Now this is key,
because they are used differently than
other devices like a phone or tablet.
The UI is different.
They're worn,
instead of put pocket, and so on.
The second you'll notice is that
these watches are as diverse as
the broad set of users who wear them.
You might be dealing
with a square screen, or
a round screen, your user might
be a runner or might be a pilot.
Instead of fighting these issues,
embrace them by designing an app
that works great on any watch and
in any situation that makes sense.
The good news is that from the
perspective of actually writing code,
these watches look very similar
to Android phones and tablet's.
Much of the underlying
software is exactly the same.
Even the hardware is basically the same
with similar senses and functionality.
So once you learn all the new
paradigms of designing for
a wearable, you can jump in a familiar
Android territory to build it.
>> In this introductory lesson,
I'll give you an overview of the design
philosophy and
platform components of Android Wear.
But first, let's start with the demo.